Next question today is from Lopez Lopez says,
won't businesses just move to other countries
if we increase taxes on them? Basically the
answer is no, not in any statistically significant
way. This is a very common Cannard that's
floated by the anti tax right in the United
States and maybe also in in Europe, although
I followed that less closely.
The idea here is if you are a corporation,
um, and the government increases your taxes,
you would be incentivized to move your operation
to some other country that has a lower tax
rate. There's a couple of things that we have
to discuss there, but let's start with the
sort of most basic, I mean, American companies,
mostly our American. Yes, there are multinationals
which already are doing business all over
the world and they can more easily move their
headquarters if not all physical presence.
But what you have to remember is a lot of
those companies have already established all
sorts of tax shelters and havens. So that's
not going to dramatically change if they've
already determined, well we do better by having
an Irish headquarters, but we still have the
American presence because we have the United
States is such a major market. Um, that is
one reason why they are not going to say we're
going to relinquish our position in the United
States altogether.
The other thing you have to remember is even
though you might be able to avoid some American
business taxes, if you move your operation
to another country, um, then you risk having
added tariffs if you still want to do business
with American consumers and corporations.
And that in some cases may end up sort of
zeroing out the tax benefit. But most importantly,
all but the biggest businesses are simply
not going to move to other countries. If you
consider all small businesses and even most
medium size businesses that operate primarily
in the United States, uh, if you have a huge
roofing company or a construction company,
not like a local construction company, but
the big real estate companies and you basically
work in the u s why are you going to move
to another country? It doesn't make any sense.
Uh, it's logistically, uh, significant. Uh,
it's a, it's a logistically significant undertaking
and you're an American company with American
customers and all Americans speaking, uh,
American English speaking employees.
So it's just not practical to think that that's
what people are going to do. Now the, we actually
have some data where we can analyze this because
the same claim has been made for a really
long time about rich people. It's easier for
a rich person to move to another country or
to a lower tax state than it is for a huge
company to move from one country to another.
And it turns out that millionaires don't move
very much. Millionaires actually move way
less than poor people. About half the rate.
Only 2.4% of millionaires move in any given
year versus 4.5% of poorer Americans. And
interestingly, when millionaires do decide
to move, they slightly favor lower tax states.
Slightly many millionaires are moving to higher
tax states. Many millionaires moved to the
states with the same level of tax and some
millionaires moved to lower tax states and
for 85% of them, the tax rate in the state
they are moving to is not an important consideration.
If you go from looking at millionaires to
looking at billionaires, 84% of billionaires
live in their country of birth period, and
there's no solid evidence that tax rates are
influencing them in terms of where it is that
they want to live. But here's the really important
part. 84% of of billionaires live in their
birth country. 16% of billionaires don't live
in their birth country, but almost all of
them moved to that country before they were
billionaires. Meaning that if the tax rate
was a consideration, it was a consideration
in some vague, distant way. If they ever are
billionaires, they'd be better off in one
country versus another rather than, I'm moving
now because I want to save money on taxes.
So of course when you get to the margins you
have to consider if a government puts ridiculously
high taxes on corporations, it is going to
serve as more of an incentive to move country
for that reason.
What we're talking about in the United States
about eliminating loopholes and write offs
and some of these other mechanisms that exist
for corporations to end up paying almost no
taxes or sometimes no taxes or even getting
tax credits even though they made profit.
Uh, for the most part, these are changes well
within the sort of reasonable that are not
going to cause a, those businesses to relocate.
I'm sure you can find individual instances
of anything in a country of 330 million people.
Uh, but from a macro economic level, it's
been widely, widely debunked.